[Music]
we're still not over Incredibles - what
an amazing movie but what's even better
is seeing the fans getting inspired by
the characters and trying to recreate
their look in real life don't forget to
hit that notification belt and never
miss another video and be sure to check
out our community section for even more
fun now let's check out Incredibles -
characters in real life
violet par let's start out with the one
and only violet par who doesn't want to
be like her we'd love to have the power
to be invisible check out this amazing
real-life cosplay by Yuta rx-78 - from
deviantART although she probably
couldn't become invisible as a human she
definitely has the powers to turn
herself into an incredible scare achter
check her out as violet that is pretty
spot-on
we love this superhero poses but we are
really impressed by the fact that she
does indeed look like by that power it
might be a simple outfit to put together
but we love the colours the iconic
orange head scarf of course just adds to
it Elastigirl now hillman power aka mrs.
incredible is a completely different
story
while violets powers are quite limiting
Helen aka elastic girl can stretch out
all her limbs pretty cool right
elasticity also brings her other powers
like shape-shifting and more check out
how this use from deviantART reimagined
what elastic girl would look like in
real life
isn't that pretty spot-on we love that
hair girl too bad we couldn't also see
her silver suit from the second movie
although Helen couldn't even have it on
for that long anyway red outfit for the
win this picture belongs to OKs photo
who also did an amazing job
jack-jack who doesn't love the power
family they're pretty awesome but if we
had to pick the most adorable member it
would definitely be Jack Jack he's just
way too cute despite the fact that he
doesn't get as much screen time as the
rest of the fam but oh my goodness
wait until you see a real-life Jack Jack
with mrs. incredible this image belongs
to deviantART user recce Conran who's
also real-life Jack Jack's mother
despite being the youngest
Jack Jack comes with the most powers of
them all and we wonder what kind of
secret powers does this real-life Jack
Jack hold syndrome okay we have to talk
about syndrome he might be a villain but
The Incredibles just wouldn't be the
same
without him well at least the first
movie since he doesn't make that much of
an appearance in the second yeah we're
still salty about that sorry but his
character lives on and any Incredibles
cosplayer can prove that check out the
princess pan on deviantART and her
awesome cosplay work a syndrome we're
totally in love with that hair and that
awesome pose this photo belongs to the
talented Gabe Duvall media who did an
amazing job at capturing this awesome
cosplayer Edna when it comes to our
favorite characters Edna has it all
speaking of important characters who
really made this movie Edna really is
the ultimate super villain if you
watched our Incredibles Theory videos
you know all possible hidden secrets
Edna holds but we had no idea you can
find a real-life Edna out there check
out Aurora Celeste from deviantART
doesn't she look adorable in her Edna
cosplay we all know Edna has talent for
designing fashion but it looks like this
cosplayer knows how to rock it to
Frozone lucious best aka Frozone is mr.
Incredibles best friend
although Frozone had a bigger role in
the first movie he still tried to save
the world in the second well we say try
because the plot twists continued to
challenge him but he's still an
important character and we couldn't not
feature this cosplayers work check it
out gravity skater from deviantART as
lucious best aka Frozone we adore the
light blue and white outfit and of
course the superhero stance if something
goes wrong in our life we're definitely
calling the real-life Frozone to the
rescue Elastigirl
and Edna what's more fun than looking at
single real-life characters from The
Incredibles looking at multiple
characters hanging out together
sometimes we forget that these are
actually cosplayers they're so good
check out these two cuties it's elastic
girl in her silver outfit and the one
and only Edna this image belongs to moe
moe Kurumi on deviantART and the photo
was taken by death comm media don't
these two look adorable we totally want
to see more of a last girl in her silver
outfit which one do you think looks
better on her come let us know in the
comments
mr. and mrs. incredible let's get to the
ultimate power couple that really is
excuse the fun incredible these two are
hash tag couple goals and it looks like
even real-life versions can replicate
that chemistry pretty easily check it
out this photo belongs to retro Enzo
from deviantART and while we're not sure
whether these two are actually together
as a couple
the fact that they're cosplaying as mr.
and mrs. incredible makes them an
instant power couple and we're totally
here for it but what's even better than
real-life mr. and mrs. incredible seeing
all characters from real-life all
characters of course these are still
just cosplayers
as there is no way technology would
allow us to meet animated characters and
interact with them yet but when it does
we'll be the first ones in line check
out this photo of all the characters
from The Incredibles in one place this
photo belongs to baby sparrow from
deviantART check them out everyone is
here Edna Frozone violet syndrome yup
all accounted for although they might
not have any superpowers their power is
clearly cosplaying and it's amazing on
its own we bet they could turn into any
character they want DIY so do you want
to become your own version of a
real-life character from The Incredibles
luckily for you you don't have to make
your own costume like most of the
cosplayers do The Incredibles has such a
popular fanbase you can find their
costumes online for edna's character you
just need to find our clothes the right
wig some glasses and voila Edna
personified dressing as the characters
might not give you superpowers but it's
still pretty cool to see real-life
versions of The Incredibles who's your
favorite character come let us know in
the comments and that's it for our video
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]